you
thank you everyone thanks for being here
thanks for taking the time to listen to
me I'll try to make it short and sweet
and so it's great to be back at the GSB
I'm here today to talk about how to in
my experience with our learn is how to
build a performance culture in a
corporate environment and I it's it's
very simple but it's at the same time
very tough to do it on a daily basis and
I'll show you some examples and relate a
lot to sports in life in academia here
at business school for example one of
the things that first things I like to
throw it use the provocation in that
until the age of 10 to 24 years old all
of us have been through school high
school college sports in some sort of
form and we all accept a lot of things
as being you know natural so the fact
that there was a coach and sports that
the coach relates directly don't
delegate that with the players that
there is a locker room talk lots of
pleasure being put in the players before
the game straight feedback players that
are playing well played players they're
not playing so well or sold or stay in
the bench where poor performance is
dealt with where amazing performance is
recognized and awarded where people are
treated differently according to their
talents and performance and track record
all this is natural you know at school
the same thing I mean the best students
you know there are in the RJ's List and
the 10% top they got scholarships they
got recognized they got named there is a
ranking in sports and yes there are
people at the bottom and that's the idea
that people at the bottom feel bad and
they want to go to the top so yeah
that's the idea to create attention so
we live with that and we think that all
makes sense and then it dated 20 to 24
we go to the corporate world and all
sudden a lot of things that were so
natural and made so much sense in a
corporate world because of many things
corporate branding peer pressure
politically correct way of doing things
whatever you want to label it you'll
start being feeling that you can
do what you used to do before so a lot
of people for example in big
corporations say I don't have time to
recruit people you know I sent somebody
else I'm too high up in the organization
and I think HR people would have to deal
with that you know I want them to bring
me the best talent then they'll work
with me but I'm not going to do it
myself and I don't have time I having a
busy agenda again can you imagine can
you imagine the coach you know saying to
somebody else hey I don't have time go
talk to my players real select players
and go you know do the locker room clock
for me before the very important game
because I'm doing something else
managing some paperwork
no can't imagine a teacher a professor
coming to class and saying well today
I'm going to send an assistant to teach
because I don't have time for my
students so I'm going to do that so now
of course you cannot imagine but when
you go to a company you think it's
natural to hire a headhunter to hire or
just to ask somebody the HR to do this
for you when you go to a big company you
see low performance and you want to act
on it but somehow people pressure you
you know this guy has been here for 20
years
it's a little performer for sure but I
mean you know maybe maybe next year I
mean let's give it one more opportunity
again it's different from the kind of
life's you had before the corporate life
so that's the first provocation I want
to throw out there why is that when we
enter the corporate world a lot of
things that work so well in sports at
school and we're so natural when it
comes to corporate world is so kind of
it's so hard to implement and that's one
of the things my vision in my opinion
that gets a lot of companies not to be a
good or high-performing company because
they are full of this barriers okay to
action naturally second thing I wanted
to to go to table here before we start
is the whole idea that companies are
formed by people common sense of course
of course but a lot of people again when
you're in sports and you are in a tough
game and you are a half-time the players
got together and they say we have to
solve this there's no like the team will
take care of it you know we have to
solve it we have to change strategy we
have to change players
to do something different because if we
do the same we'll get the same results
if you're at school and you're
performing badly in a subject and you
have a final next week you have to do
with it you're going to ask somebody I
mean you can ask for help but at the end
of the day it's you is going to go there
and write the exam so it's you you have
to fix it it's not the company when you
go to the corporate world also there is
this image of this idea perception that
there is something of a higher hierarchy
called the company and so you are you
have a problem you say yeah I'm sure the
company will come with something and
they don't tell us what to do and yeah
let's wait and then maybe they will
think of something and you know there's
this thing like a company with some
spirit in a black room you know that you
slip your slip messages underneath the
door with the question and they will
answer back to you you never see them
because they are the company and now I
mean the company is us I mean myself and
a hundred thousand other colleagues of
mine the other company if we're excited
knowing what we want to do aligned
inspired moving forward learning
attracting better people than we are all
the time the company is moving in that
direction it's progressing it's growing
if we're all going different directions
waiting for somebody else to solve our
problems not acting on things we should
act like low performance or poor
performance and you know feeling that
you know we're big everything's going to
be fine we'll never fail that's the
first step into failing and that doesn't
get you to be a great great company so
with these two ideas now let's go into
what we learned three things that create
a top performing culture we're not
saying this is the only way to do it I'm
saying we've done it for 21 years and
has worked it's not perfect we'll never
be mine that has worked ok so the first
three things are dream people culture
Alec's plan because the company is us
people dream the idea of the dream is
something that comes naturally we always
had dream in our lives you know we've
always dreamt of something and that's
what keeps our doing that Monday morning
when you're tired when snowy out there
not here when it's cold
when it's cold or too warm maybe too
warm here and you feel like oh man I
have to bike to class but you have that
dream you have that dream of you know
doing well at school dating that person
you know being hired by that company
buying that car so dream is something
that for human beings click I think much
more than visions and missions missions
are for military visions are for I don't
know for whom but but dream is something
that we all understand because through
our life dream is something that has
always propped up you know propped us up
the next step so in our company we don't
have vision where I have a mission we
have a dream we're going to be the best
in what we do in a better world that's
it okay and why is it dream important
first because again it's about human
beings second because dream big or dream
small takes the same amount of energy
think about that one of the other thinks
the same amount of energy so why not
dream big you know if you don't get for
yourself nobody will knock at your door
and say your dreams too small why don't
you aim here nobody will do that in our
experience we've always reached our
dreams never the way we planned that's
real life because you learn because
competitions are something the
environment changes but if you have a
dream that's stretched enough that you
know 80% how to get there and at the
other twenty you learn along the way you
believe it can learn along the way
that's something that can inspire people
get the bar higher and getting the bar
higher you tell the message good is not
good enough guys if you want to be the
best in what we do and go from here to
here that's the gap we need the very
best to get us there so the dream is
only good if people buy into it if they
commit to it if they bring their passion
to it that's right I don't like the word
fun I think fun is too weak I don't like
people our company to have fun I have
fun at the beach with my kids I like
people in the company to have fun Shore
Plus passion plus commitment plus energy
plus lots of other things you know
fineness to week you know if you want to
be the best one what we do but there are
differences again the dream is to be
something that inspires and credible
enough
by into it because you have to work hard
it's not a target it's a dream and by
definition it's a tough one it's at
rational it's not an adventure if you
put out there an adventure and say guys
we're going to double the value of the
company next year if people say oh my
god okay you're going to commit to that
I'm going do something else that's an
adventure an adventure is when you know
20% how to get there and you believe
wrongly in our experience that 80% you
can discover along the way dreams the
opposite you know 80% how to get there
but at 20% stretch as per our experience
is what you can you learn when the
learning curve calking from others
tripping over things that you didn't
know we're there or just you know
learning from the environment that's a
dream and your dream has to be powerful
enough to commit people and again dream
big or small takes the same amount of
energy the other thing about the dream
that's very important is that dream big
it brings the best of people think about
this think about the high jump
I mean dream is about this I mean you
put the trash hold here you put the bar
here who which human being having the
bar here even if the guy could would
jump here because we're rational we
optimize energy we optimize time so if
the bar is here we're going to jump
enough to clear the hurdle even if you
can jump here so the idea of the dream
is that is the high jump is to keep
putting the ball higher so you can see
what you the company the team the group
can do and as a leader you have it's an
art and science you have to keep putting
that bar higher and higher and you find
that limit with what you have today and
then you learn some more and then next
year you can do a bit higher but with
what learn what's the maximum
performance you can deliver so that's
the first thing and that's very
important because if you don't buy into
the dream a lot of things I'm going to
say from now on don't make any sense if
you're just trying to survive the
company nine to six you know just have a
job because I have other interests and
that's it forget it that's not the
company for you that kind of company ok
so that's why the dream is very
important second thing you can only have
dreams you have people because people
don't want reaming ok
couple things great companies are formed
by great people obvious but so many
people forget about it
people think that great companies are
formed by great products great cash flow
great installations assets asset base no
even the consumer goods company what
distinguishes you from an average
company is the kind of people can
attract retain deploy develop train
promote within your company that's it
because behind the brand that's doing
well on the market you have people that
understood consumers had these sites
executed according to the insights and
put translated all that behind the brand
that's why the brands successful not
because of the brand the brand was there
was the second step first step was to
have great people ok so again great
companies can only be formed by great
people second thing great people attract
more great people that's important
because the opposite is very sad
mediocre people attract more mediocre
people they like to work together now
it's amazing mediocre people love to
work together because nobody challenges
anybody the targets that they give to
each other are kind of you know easy you
know 120 percent how to get there
January 1st so it's a piece of cake
everything is fine the feedbacks in your
yearly performance evaluation is always
like you're a great guy no gaps I mean
you're terrific it gonna be the next
president of this company or that you
know you're so great mediocre people
they love that great people's the
opposite they love to challenge each
other they don't take it personal
because they know it's for the bad for
the best of the business they know it's
not about themselves about the business
so you can check they know there's no
hidden agenda so it can challenge them
in meetings because it's all about
what's best for the business and they
like to work with each other because by
challenging one another they keep
raising the bar and that brings the best
in you that forces you to continue to be
updated and learn because everybody else
is pressuring you that's right so good
to hire people that are better than you
because they force you to be better if
you hire a whole bunch of media
people that you'd think that you're the
greatest guy on earth you're gonna get
start going like this because you have
no incentive no push to get better okay
that's the other thing
what's great you say I'm saying great
people attract more of great people
what's great if there is a lack of
definition anywhere just take you and
your colleagues as a benchmark let's see
if we were great but if if this is what
we know myself and my colleagues I want
to hire people that with the right
training and the right development can
be better in some years than we are
today that's great and smart people are
not afraid of that made your core people
are very afraid of that they don't want
very bright people in their teams
because hey that's kind of overshadow me
that's going to pick me out of job you
know smart people even for the wrong
reasons they arrive at the same place
that's much better to have a team of
high achievers because that while pew
was a leader to get to your targets in a
more consistent way and it will help you
to get promoted faster because you have
a pipeline of people so even if you're
selfish so if you're thinking about the
wrong things only think about you not
about the business you get to the same
place but it's better to having your
team great people very talented people
because that will be good for you and if
you think in a more noble way that's the
best thing for the company okay so we
look at leaders and one of the traits
that we look at what's the capacity that
they have to form find recruit retain
develop people because leaders that can
only use people that were developed by
others they're good leaders but they're
not the ones that will get you 20 years
from now 30 years from now with the kind
of pipeline that you need okay okay so
we're talking about great people in our
experience what does well what kind of
environment keeps great people on board
because great people are very volatile
they could be especially here in Silicon
Valley and if you have something you
know somebody who's very good will be
hard but somebody else two years here
when you're here wait people in our
experience like three things I like to
work a place where meritocracy is the
name again or if formality
the way things are done and we're candor
is the way to go
okay meritocracy easier said than done
again sports of course meritocracy the
good players play the others don't in
school of course if you have an F you
know exactly what it means you fail if
you have an A you got the scholarship of
course but then you got to the company
performance evaluations and that that
straightforward because they say no
today is a Friday poor guy I mean put me
and put him and then work for her I'll
wait for the Monday May money you're
traveling if a year goes by two years
ten years and you never said your
coworker what this person needs to to
listen you play God you play God you say
no no I'm going to manage it this way
I'm not going to say today because I
think by himself for some you know
strange reason he's going to click to it
get better and therefore I can avoid
this you know moment that we're going to
have now you know of course it never
happens because this click it doesn't
happen constructive feedback is what you
have people to get better my life I what
I learned to constructive and respectful
feedback that's what gets you to
progress people that are interested in
your success but for that you have to
have tough conversations it's not
everything rosy okay so again they like
meritocracy and think about this it's so
easy again peer pressure you go to a
company you lead a business unit you
have a vacancy somebody got promoted and
you have to fill that vacancy and then
in sports you go for the best player but
in the company people suppression you
and say well what about what about Mike
Mike has been here for 20 years and then
he deserves it you know okay he's not
the sharpest tool in the Dan but I'm in
it's pretty good people like him I'm
sure it's going to be okay and then you
have Jane or just drawing two years ago
and you know deserves that big time
because built a track record is a
cultural ambassador has potential will
do it it's much about a fit and
sometimes if you promote Mike nobody
will ask you questions but Jane if you
promote Jane Jane you all to ask you a
question but everybody else will
guess what remote mic Jane sees through
that and she's leave and Sheila and she
leaves and all sudden you laughed with
only the mediocre people who thinks that
the singer patronizing and promoting the
senior guys is the best thing to do as
opposed to meritocracy the worst thing
in the company since you cannot please
everybody that's another lesson that I
learned time and time again if you
cannot please everybody please the most
talented ones I'd rather have the most
talented people saying this is my
company and people going to made yoga
say aw man that's a drag I'm guy I think
I'm going to leave this company no great
they're going to leave the company so
because sometimes the way to solve a
problems to create a problem that's why
when you have a poor performing guy it
should give 2/3 feedbacks of course
because people again they grow with
feedback constructive positive feedback
but after three feedback so he went past
the guys not performing it's better for
both of you to let that guy go first
because you create a problem that they
can see and in creating a problem you
have to solve the problem if the guys
remains there for another ten years
because you don't have the problem you
don't have the urge to solve the problem
so create the problem let the guy go
because that guy could be a huge success
of another company but not here so don't
waste his time life's too short don't
weigh his or time kill him or her what
they need to know and move on okay so
that sounds like harsh but it's not
think about sports that's what happens
and we accept it not say we like it but
we accept it
another thing that great people like is
informality informality is not the way
you dress but it's the environment you
create in the company that people can
speak up speak their minds as long as
they are constructive and respectful
that's why in our office for example
nobody has a an office space I don't
have enough space I am the CEO of the
company but I I share a big table with
my all my direct reports and in all our
offices across the globe everybody has
the same kind of layout why because that
gets information flowing that gets
people to
to connect in two minute meetings five
minute meetings as they interact across
the table or they meet somebody across
the corridor I think that not only
outlook will allow you to schedule five
minute meetings right I mean I got that
but if you were together with people and
you interact with Guardian two minutes
is talking about Brazil and we interact
two minutes here and then somebody asks
about something and you're interacting
here five minutes bank you get much
stuff done and people are exposed both
ways so no place to hide much better for
you to get to know people who is doing
what so open environment is something
that great people like mediocre people
would love to be behind a closed door
right playing games and stuff and you
know yeah and yeah so candor cancers the
other thing I mean talented people like
to know where they stand because they
know life's too short they know they
have other options even in tough
economies talented people always have
options and you have to tell them where
they stand this is going well this is a
gap we do it twice a year and you know
this is the plans what's your future
here what you think what are the next
steps talented people like that talented
people high-maintenance people it's much
easy to work with mediocre people in
that respect they never come to you they
try to hide from you
right they love the closed doors
talented people ask you every day what's
what about my future am i doing okay I
have an idea I don't think this is going
well I think the company is missing this
opportunity I mean it's high maintenance
but it's much better to have that and to
have people that don't want to talk to
you and when you talk to them they have
no ideas they think the status quo is
the best thing that can happen right
which is never the case especially in
the moments in the kind of world we live
today so again just trying to to
summarize meritocracy the thing about
people that you need to dedicate time
with people just like a coach in a
successful sports team would do it think
about that for 20 years of my life that
was the case why should I forget all
that and start behaving in a we
a low-performing type way to build a low
performance cultures that what we want
after all these years of study in
Business School of course not the other
thing that's very important for guys
like you that are going to be leaders in
the organization is to know what kind of
pressure to put in the system look at
the Olympics World Cup I mean the Giants
when they were playing their games the
World Series I mean congratulations by
the way
and it took 50 years but fine yeah but
yeah but I mean you look at professional
athletes playing you're not having fun
when they're about to play think about
100 meter 100 meter dash they filmed
those guys do we focus they're not
thinking about anything else other than
to get from here to here in nine seconds
or whatever okay so they're totally
focused and there's a lot of pressure
built from the fact that you have 60,000
people watching them their contracts you
know their family their wives or whoever
in a company if you want the best of
people as a leader you have to put
pressure all the time if you put too
much pressure people panic that's bad
that's bad if you put too little
pressure people having a great time you
know the targets are easy and you don't
expect too much I mean if we grow half
of what we could that's fine I mean
that's okay we'll pay bonus for that as
well and you know shareholders didn't
get their value
there was over the creation but we'll
pay borrows anyway and that kind of
thing and I know you won't get the best
of people and again the great people
will leave they don't like this kind of
environment so as a leader you need to
know that people all of us we are at our
best when we are under pressure healthy
pressure think about school when when do
you really get your mind around things
this is when you have a deadline right I
mean you have a deadline you have that
work that you need to deliver to more
men
you are as focused as a razor blade and
you don't think about anything you can't
so everything is social gender goes to
hell your Facebook is off everything is
off you know
you just you just work on that thing you
know that's when the when you get the
best of you when you get transferred
within a company to a what we like to do
that a lot where we call the crazy
promotions we got a guy from sales put
the guy supply chain for itself because
we believe that that's the way to build
people and again the magic word take
people out of their comfort zone
whenever we are in a place that's too
comfortable that's bad that's bad you
have to take from time to time people
from their comfort zone because that's
when this whole idea of the athlete's
100 meter dash board that focus that
thing oh my god I had three months to
learn this little job that's when you
really move to the next level if she
stay 10 years in the same job not saying
the same company a lot of people stay in
20 years 30 years in our company but
then here's doing the same thing the
same job in the same region I mean at
some point it gets stale I mean it got
used to landscape you know see you know
a from B back from Wyatt because
everything has been there for such a
long time and you can only learn this
much per day and is you don't learn
because it used to it you're not going
to recover that going forward so you're
wasting your time okay so that's very
important to that whole pressure take
people out of the comfort zone that's
the way to develop great people the
third leg of the stool is culture so a
spoke about dream people now culture
culture know a company recall it's a
culture of ownership we don't like the
word professionals executives we like
the word owners think about this owners
of the guys that live and die by their
business because that's all they have if
you have a bakery and that's where you
get your livelihood from that bakery has
to succeed failure is not an option and
you have to be competitive you have to
understand your customers you cannot
lose customers to Walmart just because
they open across the street
you have to rethink your business but
that's your business
you're not going to hop onto the next
job that's your life so owners we like
corners because of that because they're
going to leave with the consequences of
their decision I like to give you an
example that caused me already some
trouble but I keep going back to the
same example of the rental car okay it
doesn't happen to me but I've heard some
people right drive a rental car
in a different way then they drive their
own car I have it doesn't happen later
some people like to try things weird
things in rental cars and you know
experiments experiments again I've heard
that I've heard even people that say
don't be gentle it's a rental see how
see how weird people can be I tell it's
well out there is weird place but I'm in
a rental car why why do I do this people
behave like that with a rental car I
think because it's they're not going to
live with the consequences of their
driving so they're going to drive
experiment there will be consequences to
the car they'll give back the car to the
one of those companies and somebody else
will live the consequence next day your
car let's go to your car today two more
next month next year next five years
you're driving a different way we want
our card to be your company not not like
a rental company and we have lots of
stuff that we do within the company from
all the way to share ownership which is
the classic way but more important than
that is the mindset we believe that
people to have shares options variable
compensation which are very aggressive
that they first need to have the
ownership mindset and there are many
things in the company that we do to
foster that environment that this is my
machine if I work at a brewery plant and
I have a Kenny line or a brew house this
is my part of the world there are some
rules this is the sandbox but within the
sandbox I own it we would fail if people
would have to ask at some point would
have failed if at some points our key
guys have to ask the questions what
about if I had my own business this is
your business that's the environment we
try to foster it's a big startup we
always say that we like that flexibility
of a startup where people always trying
to do new things within of course some
very days agreed rules so we don't lose
advantage of being a large company so
the rental-car example is one that I
like because I think it talks to the
essence of ownership and we all
understand that at least some people
understand that
I think other things about our culture a
lot of people say they're very focused
on the consumer we say that too because
the consumers is the boss that's right I
mean think about this people don't need
to buy beverages if tomorrow they decide
just to drink water out of the tap I
mean I would have no business okay and
most of our competitors would have no
business so it's that simple right so
but we try to take that to the next
level
for example we try to take that - the
way we manage the company I try to think
if the guy by my stellar twaf is paying
a premium over my Budweiser Bud Light or
the products what do they expect me to
do with that money
as a consumer if I have lavish offices
and corporate jets and you know five
course meals when I travel and Four
Seasons and all that we always say the
asset test when our consumers be proud
if they knew we spend their money like
that or they feel better if we have a
lien company where we have more money to
spending things that are important for
them an NFL sponsorship a major league
ball sponsorship the Olympics the World
Cup so many things that they like that
they see as a return for what they're
paying for the product so we try to be
lean not only because the right thing to
do but because our consumers would be
proud of us knowing that we're managing
their money in a way to have more to
give back as opposed to spend in between
friends in the company you know so we're
very lean because we believe so we call
this the cost connect win the more
non-working dollars that are dollars
that consumers are not willing to pay a
premium for because they don't see it
they don't touch it don't drink it don't
take home don't pay for it
so non-working dollars the more we get
non-working dollars to become working
dollars things that consumers value the
more we connect with them because they
see we're giving back to them the more
we win more business and more consumers
cross-connect win and that's why the way
to grow companies all is always and
we're going to say here the finance 101
top-line and cost efficiencies they're
both but if you only do cause it's a
short thing can only do so much and the
way to get people excited about
because a tough thing to get people
excited about is to connect that with
the top line saying the more money we
find here the more we're going to revert
back to the market place where it
matters and the more consumers in
business will win okay leadership that's
important thing in our culture our
culture is only passed from person to
person by means of leadership your
actions as well know I'm more important
than words what's important about
leadership I'm tell you in five minutes
what we discovered first who is the
leader in the company we say anybody who
needs a team to get to a target if you
can get to a target by yourself in that
role you're not being a leader you don't
need to be a leader you're not a
leadership position because by yourself
you can get your target if you need the
team to get together to a target you're
in the leadership position what's the
definition of leadership companies is
what I mean people write books about it
we have three three dimensions
leadership is all about delivering
results and a consistent basis with your
team because my the very definition
cannot do it alone do it the right way
so you can build on top and you can
replicate the way you did it to other
parts of the business that's leadership
leadership is a very important trait in
a guys like Hugh that are going to join
companies they're hard to define but you
know when you see a good one this three
things are just basic definitions but I
like to see I like to say other things
about leadership leadership is a guy
that can see the wall out there which is
a very complex world and translate that
V analysis into simple things think
about this I have added 100 plus
thousand people in our company we have
70,000 that are sales reps they're very
smart there's street smart but I don't
have time to explain them everything
that happens in the marketplace in terms
of deep dive studies analysis that we do
elasticity is everything we do in the
marketplace not because they can get it
because they don't have time they're
busy
the other ones bringing the money in
tasting the customers they need to have
customer facing time so as a leader we
need to understand the world out there
which is very complex but translate that
into two three five action things
that can be done by 80,000 people think
about the automobile think about the
automobile how many of us drive here
everybody think about if we have to
understand about thermodynamics
mechanical engineer you know metal I
mean everything that goes into a car
under the hood somebody was smart enough
to put two pedals and a steering wheel
and a shift and everybody drives even
without knowing what's under the hood
that's genius I mean you took a very
complex type machine and you made it so
simple to operate that billions of
people around the world can operate
that's the thing about leadership in a
company 90% of the people in the company
if you were to compare with the ship
need to be running the engine room but
you need some people in the bridge
looking at at the bridge looking at what
the ship's going but the 90% doesn't
know to know that they need to because
they have a busy life very busy life so
leadership's about that leadership's
about not being selfish you have
questions about your company try to get
them clear because your reference to
your team ok so those are some things
about leadership the other thing last
one in cultures no shortcuts we work a
lot with Jim Collins they used to be a
professor here at business school I met
him in 88 87 when I was here and he
works a lot with us and once I taped an
interview with him for a global
conference of ours and I asked Jim I
read I read your book good to great for
me it's so common sense it's even better
because it's based on research so it's
not your opinions based on research
why would companies choose not to do
what's in your book if that's a recipe
book to go from good to great and it
says Brito you know what the problem is
in my research and context with
companies our companies start with the
same good you know ideas and the good
intent but at some point they start
looking for shortcuts so instead of
forming their own people building their
own bench strength they go in the market
and hire somebody else did their job for
that right instead of hiring somebody
out of school 22 years old and form this
guy to be a great worked here why not go
to a great marketing company or out
there at P&G or Coke or Pepsi and as a
Busch InBev and
somebody from this company right but
then you have people from all the
companies and you don't have the culture
the fabric that holds everybody together
and that takes 20 years to build it's in
one month it's gone
so that's why in his view and I agree a
lot of good companies never got to be
great because they are looking for
shortcuts they don't want to then
understand that to build a great company
it takes time it's brick by brick person
by person
yes takes a long time but once you build
it and you keep the gap to your
competitors it's hard for them to catch
up because a lot of the things I'm
talking about here dream people culture
is very invisible said about a better
product what about this will come as
well
but sum up what's behind that's
invisible that's hard to touch it takes
ten years to build to finish up let me
see let me tell you this for me that's
the best kept secret in our company not
say it's the only way to do it I'm just
say it's the best kept secret you know
what because every time I talk about
this not to you but you know from people
from other companies other CEOs and
stuff the reaction I get is that of
course but this is so common sense I
mean you're having a dream so a big idea
hiring the very best people and then
having this culture of ownership it's
your company no shortcuts and stuff and
for me it's great that they think like
that especially my competitors because
they take it for granted that take it
for granted and they don't do what we
try to do which is not take it for
granted talk about it every single time
we have an opportunity to do a town hall
to do a Q&A with our employees I always
do a 10-minute drinkable culture
introduction and then to give time you
know to warm up and then it is because
this is what we're all about this is
what brought us here from very small
company to the top five consumer goods
couple very humble to say that because
we have to earn it every day there's no
such a thing as all we got there no no
no the more you go up the more you have
to fall to fall we know that so in a
very humble way but at least I can show
you this is not a concept with no proof
the other thing I can tell you is that
we grew a company organically and also
through M&A and as a bush being the last
one we did but in the last 12 years we
did five cross country's big
combinations as we call it
and in every time we combine with the
company in all sector we ask the
questions because we could see at the
guts of our competitors in different
countries say ok why we perform as a
company on average we're not perfect far
from it but on average performing better
than this other company and the only
answer I could always get to was dream
people culture in the sense that we had
a group of people that ain't higher had
a sense of purpose better higher more
elevated then there's other company I
had people that were better more
talented and have a culture of ownership
this is my company not my job and that
made a huge difference so with that I'd
like to open for questions thank you
very much
yes there's a question here to drive
that culture down into the organization
you know four levels deep how do you
make sure that those managers are
creating that type of culture a very
good point very good point we do that
for example the best the best example
would be for example get the demerger we
did with and has a Busch the Budweiser
company just two years ago in the midst
of this whole financial crisis and stuff
what we do and this was the fifth one we
did it we learned that when you do such
a thing you have to start talking when I
went there to st. Louis that the after
we signed the merger agreement I went
there by gathered the top leadership the
company always spoke about was dream
people culture because once you set that
framework every question you go back to
that framework so when they said what's
your opinion about this I said well as
you said and we have a thing called 1010
principles so dream people culture for
us if you go to our website you see it's
a ten principle thing you know one for
dream two for people seven for culture
and it's great the great frame for you
to anchor things and what you have to do
in our experience to change when they
talk about culture it's it's important
to say that we believe a lot in national
cultures what I want to change those
that's why we travel that's why I life's
so interesting when you travel because
people dress differently spend their
free time in a different way
have different family ties eat
differently that's why we travel
different architecture but the company
now we say it's one company one culture
we have zero complacency for differences
in basic stuff like a constitution of a
country so this company that's going to
join us this is how we operate and I
never met anybody who said I don't agree
with this should I be a high-performing
just like an athlete that's what you
have to do have a dream surround
yourself with great people work hard
that's what you have to do but I'm not
up for it I've met some people that said
that I'm in a stage of my life and this
and that I'm not up for it and but I
think if you want to do what you want to
do that's I agree with this so what we
do is we try to get the leadership of
the company because in a companies all
of this you
have percent who are the leaders 70%
will follow
mostly what the leaders because the use
of leaders are as as their you know
place for QA and inspiration and all
that if the leaders are good leaders and
you have at the bottom 10 or 15%
whatever the balance that always against
anything you know
so Soto guys you have to identify and
bank out I think what was good in this
last transaction that we did is that the
first layer of management left day one
for different reasons some because they
were retiring some because they were too
rich to care because of the price we
paid and some because we felt it
wouldn't have a good fit it was great
because then we promoted a lot of new
people that have been waiting for that
opportunity and this new people said
this is my company now and I like the
stuff you know because it's all about
high performance meritocracy openness
you know candor that's my company I've
been waiting for so now let's do this
according to this so it's all about
making sure you have the right leaders
because the right leaders will get that
out of 60 or 70% of the people along
with them and they'll also identify the
the bad apples and take them out and
there is the bottom 10-15 percent that
for sure will have to go out yeah but
it's about the leadership yeah question
here
OKs go quick question go then speaking
of opportunities and the free speech and
an organization and cultures and
countries that always have have always
ingrained in a deference to Authority
for exact there your question China for
example or in yeah a rush in any
authoritarian country that's very good
example you're right when we when we
started expanding as a company we had
that that thing in mind and and the one
I was talking to you about national
cultures we said okay are we going to be
able to find people in all those other
different cultures that we're going to
go you know the four national cultures
that were brought up in a different way
that will you know get excited about the
way we're trying to build our company or
not and the fact of the matter yes you
can find you find a lot of people in
those places that have been looking for
this kind of thing because they came
from sports they came from a competitive
school and they know that that's what
build great performance and they're just
waiting for an opportunity to go to a
corporation where those things are
accepted allowed but you're right you
have to look harder in places like some
of the ones relation but over there
you'll find great people that have that
are looking for that kind of place where
they can be themselves okay so it is
possible yeah go so my questions on
delegation and how do you you may be
using your sports analogy you know great
coaches know when to direct their team
and when to just trust that their team
will figure it out and how do you kind
of translate that into the business as
being a leader and when to delegate and
when to make the decision yourself I
think that's that's a very good question
I think the the the people that we value
in our business it's a very different
mix as you go up the organization you
have to keep that apparently that false
dilemma that you have to think more you
know what the company is going
strategically but you cannot lose
statute the business that's why we try
to have fewer layers in the company open
office space okay
we value leaders that can ask questions
that are very detailed but not losing
sight of the big picture that's what we
value because people when they're having
meat
with me they know I'm not seeing them
the best but I mean they know because
I've been the company for a long time
that I can ask questions special sales
because that's my background detailed
questions I always say that when they go
to a meeting board meeting 80% of the
board meeting is my preparation the
benefit that I have to go to a board
meeting 80% is myself getting prepared
for that conversation I have a tough
board
20% I learned on the board I think the
meetings I have with my people is the
same thing 80% is then preparing with
their people to try to understand the
drivers the root causes of issues and
come prepared 20% will come in our
discussion by 80% some preparation but
this this capacity to not lose sight of
the big picture but feel comfortable in
selecting one a few areas and there you
go deep that's appreciated by the
organization because they say oh I can
count on him to help us here and that
also gets your meetings to be much more
productive because people prepare
because they know at some point you can
ask here or there they never know ok
you cannot micromanage the company
that's bad is if you micromanage the
company you create a whole bunch of
people like sometimes sometimes in the
army that I use to follow orders we want
people to think but they should know
that despite here thinking more
strategically most of the times that you
can go deep that's why we go a lot to
the market with visit the market we hear
from customers we like to be with our
frontline people because that's where
you learn what's going on yeah two
questions real quick how do you continue
to push yourself out of your comfort
zone and two what's your favorite beer
yeah I favorite beers Budweiser
the king appears for 20 years for 20
years we had this dream of doing
something with them with anheuser-busch
never worked and it finally worked after
20 years so that that's something that
we always had in our minds as as the
beer that can be a global beer like
Connick brand American iconic brand so
much so as Starbucks coca-cola Pepsi so
many other iconic brands that sell some
so well around the world America
continues to be an aspirational place
I'm not American I'm Brazilian
but I recognize that through research
America continues to be a magnet for
young people around the world talented
people young people people that want to
make things happen and have an
opportunity they all want to come here
Americans take it for granted but people
from outside value I know that the
opportunities are here - your first
question what was it again continue how
do you continue to push yourself out of
your comfort zone - thanks
from from underneath and from above I
mean first I'm very critical of myself
has always been so people say when I'm
critical to other people and tough on
other people they say burrito we accept
that because you know you're doing worse
with yourself so I'm the kind of guy
that for me to celebrate anything is
very hard that's a criticism I often get
because I'm always looking the next step
and I said yeah it was good but there's
you know but and everybody says that
what's important in the sentence is what
comes off to the butt right you should
never listen before the but when
somebody say oh yeah it was all great
and stuff but then you listen because
that's what matters so I push myself out
of my comfort zone because of the board
I have as I said and the other questions
a very tough board that forces me to up
my game all the time because I hire
people that are better than I am and
because I don't want them to get my job
anytime soon I have to keep running you
know and getting myself reinventing
myself in some respects and I'm very
critical myself as well so I think
that's the beauty of having great people
surrounding you they give you the energy
and the motivation to continue to
reinvent learn push yourself to the next
level
again if you have a whole bunch of
mediocre people you're going to feel
good about yourself you know when you
shouldn't and then you're gonna the
world will continue to do this and
you're going to be here okay questions
last question okay you sound really
ambitious and I like that I have two
questions
I have two questions the first question
is what's your next merger target
the second question is do you have any
ambitious plans to to upgrade the taste
of Budweiser
I haven't had bother bites with it for
the past ten years thanks for the
question you know you know I think and
that I we can show because it's a third
party research Budweiser in blind pests
blind test and that makes a huge
difference
I reckon in blind test is the best
liquid in the domestic market set by
consumers so our challenge is why is
that that when we label the product
people have different perceptions about
the liquid okay anyway we know that we
have a challenge there as with most
iconic brands sometimes you've fall in
that trap that the brand is so iconic
that you cannot change it consumers move
the brand stake and now consumers are
here the brands here and because of that
with the find this is a problem two
years ago when we merged because before
it was not seen as a problem because Bud
Light was you know skyrocketing and
compensating for the Budweiser slippage
but we said I don't know this two brands
are now two huge brands number one and
two in the US and in the world so we
need to give Budweiser what deserves
little a lot of research there's a lot
of positives some negatives and some
other things that we need to bring to
the buck to the brand because of its
iconic status so I very excited and if
you look at Budweiser outside of the US
it's growing like crazy passion China
your other question is about ambition I
think whenever people ask me about in
the company you know what's our next
step I always say deleveraging
deleveraging because I mean we took a
lot of money
to be able to do this transaction with a
B so we're ahead about the leverage plan
and we're very happy with it
our cash flow generation you're right
that's huge it's north of free cash of
seven eight billion a year and that's a
real problem and what to do with it but
it's a good problem to have and we'll
think about it when we have to cross a
bridge but for now we're using that cash
flow to pay down that and pay interest
to regain our freedom
okay so again guys thank you very much
for being here thanks for your time
you